- Du jus d'orange, n'importe
Tout est beau?
- M s s s s'il a vendu sa
résidence, Jean-Pierre Audet
maintient le lien é é é é é é éé
sa locataire pendant 13 ans.MONe
- J'avais affaire à l'hôpital,
bon, bien, à la stststststststs,
qui venait me reconduire.
- 14 des 16 locataires
ont quitté depuis la vente de
cette âgées en juillet.
Pourtant, le coût des loyers
a baissé, mais plusieurs
services ont disparu.
- Je vais m'ennuyer de lui;
oui, ça, c'est certain!
s'occuper d'elle pareil
mêononononon a vendu.
- Le nouveau propriétaire ne
veut pas du statut de résidences
parmi des dizaines d'autres. De,
le nombre de RPA est passé de
1259 à 1181, 78 résidences ont
donc fermé ou changé de statut,
surtout de petites résidences
comme celle-ci.
Après 13 ans, Jean-Pierre Audet
met la clé dans la porte.
ex-propriétaire de résidence
'a'a'a'a'a'aurais continué,
j'aurais continué, mais écoutez,
ils sont après nous autreeeeeeee
n'importe quoi, là.
- La reddition de compte serait
trop lourde; la mise à niveau
du bâtimentnunununununununununu,
insoluble.
- Ensuite de ça, bien là,
ils nous exigent des préposées
une petite résidence, ils nous
prenaient pour des hô
puis ainsi de suite,
puis il fallait qu'on ait
résidences.
- Les coûlolololololoitation
des résidences plombent
leur rentabilité, surtout que
à environ 2 % cette année.OROROt
québécois résidences pour aînés
- L'alimentation, en moyrgrgrgr,
électricité, 7,8 %;
le mazout, 14,8 %...
Comment est-ce qu'on peut
arriver
"Vous pouvez augmenter de 1,8 ou
2 %", mais vos coûts augmentent
- Et la pandémie a fait baisser
la demande. Le taux
d'inoccupation 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 A
est devenu moins intéressant.
Ça explique en partie pourquoi
même de grosses résidences
comme Montrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtr.
Mais plusieurs souhaitent
que Québec intervienne
et bloque ces conversions.
PIERRE LYNCH, Asso. défense des
droits des persossssssss
- Il faudrait qu'il y ait
une instance gouvernementale
plus dur que ça, là. Ça fait que
dae e e e e e e e résidence
pour personnes âgées qui a déjà
une vocation dédiée, avant
de cet édifice-là, il faudrait'n
sociale, puis l'approbation
sociale, elle se ferererererere.
popopopopopopoposent de ne
simplement plus subventionner
les résidences pour personnes
500 millions en crédit d'impôtx,
de l'argent qui pourrait
aller ailleurs.itititititititite
et informations socioéconomiques
- D'investir massivement dans
les services à domicile publics,
et c c c c c c c c c c c c c c t
justement de prendre ces crédits
d'impôt-là, qui sont empochés
par les résidences privées pour
dans les services à domicile
choisir de rester à la maison.
- Un virage qui semble urgent.
Jean-Pierre Audet disent que
même ad'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'impôt,
la rentabilité est de plus
en plus difficile.
- Si tu as 50 chambres, ça peut
être rentable, mais en bas
quelqu'un puisse bien vivre.
ubububububububububublier,
madame Gagnon, de faire un peti.
- Oui, oui!
- La passion de monsieur Audet
loin d'une froide fermeture
décidée palelelelelelelelelele.
- e e e e e e e e e e e e e e e.
- Oui.i i i i i i i i i i i Dav,
Radio-Canada, Montréal